[Music]
in never to old news too much let's be
off cue together at the same time
submitted by chicken chalupa you were
just talking I know do - Lupe's are the
best from where what's your favorite
place huh talk about baby what the fun I
know you know he likes food I don't know
it's just a Taco Bell thing
yeah like the [ __ ] gordita crunch
it's totally talked about it an 85 year
old why do you why do you want a [ __ ]
pita bread taco yeah technically that is
absolutely you're thinking about the
Gordon deep fried deep fryer keep your
del taco ass out of this conversation
[ __ ] thing oh man is good angle
delete doesn't get to it there's not
enough flavor not enough salt for me an
85 year old man has become the oldest
person to finish the Kona Ironman World
Championship holy [ __ ] and I think the
Ironman is D triathlon which means it's
because they have different distances I
don't know what the distance is but it's
probably like a [ __ ] two mile swim or
they swim - Elka try yeah dude you got
it 2.4 mile swim that's one of the
events 112 mile bike ride 26.2 mile run
and you have to complete this in under
17 hours that's a marathon yeah a
marathon is just try out of it a
marathon is part of it so there's three
events under 17 hours under 17 oh that's
crazy it's only a two mile swim
you want to hear some [ __ ] though that's
how I used to think and wells at 24 24
hour fitness I was watching this life
you know fatter man fatter than I was at
the time swimming right and I was like
this lazy foot didn't really want to
work out bro I did two laps especially
the ocean cuz you just kept it feels
like I'm [ __ ] swimming forever dude
like well we swam to that little island
in Hawaii I feel like I was swimming for
day it's not even like a quarter mile at
vegies people - like when when people
say oh do you like swimming I actually
used to think I like swim I don't like
swimming
I like floating yeah don't swim I just
yeah so this man his name is Hiro he's
85 he's Japanese Hiro mo that's pretty
impressive man damn I can't even do one
of the events right now right he
completed it and she's probably a farmer
or something I don't I just know he's
from Japan why does he why is your mom
not there's these oyster divers that are
in Japan and farmers well mainly Okinawa
where there's a bunch of like 80 to 90
year olds that's still dive in the
morning for oysters and [ __ ] mainly
women oh yeah yeah topless women right
yeah they're not topless on you anymore
petitioning and there's this one grandma
I saw she's like 80 something and she
insists on slike swimming as her husband
just like chills on the boat and then
they they they go out and so cool you
yeah she dives and then she gets back on
the boat and they come back and I'm like
who she's a boss man the husband's just
like [ __ ] that I'm going on a boat yeah
that's me yeah so yep [ __ ] merry Opie
she's Ferdinand Magellan dude she's like
exploring all over the place
she went to Idaho like this past weekend
all she did was mountain bike
she went hiking us all she did sounds ho
fun [ __ ] that
well no one were you gonna use I'm gonna
say hell of fun but I'm like I'm not
from NorCal I'm not from North Cal
hilarious like how fun we think how I
heard to know but I don't want to say I
refuse I mix my job like yo hella dead
ass yeah so this is Hugh Romo he
actually competed last year but he
missed the cutoff time in this year he
finally did it and he did it in 16 hours
53 minutes and 50 oh my god he barely
made it eighty something he does not
look 80 son that looks like 60 I'm
trying to give him a compliment
he looks 85 but now I gotta give a due
process this my it's funny because it
says Onaga honest honest sure but it
looks like image right yeah it if you
likes quit and you shake your head
really hard yeah have you guys ever
watched the triathlon no so when these
sounds boring its alibi but then if you
do like yes p.m. they show the
highlights and stuff and like the main
parts when the when the people are just
finish swimming two miles when they're
good you were like so excited to share
with us it's [ __ ] boring but when
they come out of the water cuz they they
show the transitions when they come out
of the water they're since they're so
used to moving like this for hours they
walk out and their [ __ ] legs are
trembling and they start cramping up cuz
the sea water it's [ __ ] crazy like it
took all the just the conditions like
not even just the physical demand but
the conditions and beaten going like
this for two hours and not really using
her legs in the like a running motion
people fall on the floor they faint it's
crazy more crazy he didn't start
competing in the sport until he was 71
yeah so you've just like recently under
snow dog dog don't [ __ ] sleep on 70
year olds man
[ __ ] t-shirt I'm a part of this
karate organization right and there's a
lot of practitioners you have to freeze
after that clip and people like where's
he headed towards in this conversation
right so so in our organization there's
a lot of dudes that join like in the 60s
and whatever so there's a lot of people
that are like over over 50 years old and
then I was at this karate camp it's like
a four-day boot camp right and the only
way to get a black belt in the
organization is you have to go to this
[ __ ] extensive thing they sleep
deprived you you only sleep like two
three hours
you're training three times a day right
and then my roommate he was 72 years old
yeah like a hearing aid all this [ __ ]
and then he was like I'm testing those
leave honor I'm like he's like I'm
testing for my black belt and I was like
what Dolph's plug dude the first morning
we went for a jog dude I thought he was
gonna die like I was like were you okay
man you okay like you you cooler for me
I was like you cool yeah I was like I
hope this guy's heart doesn't [ __ ]
explode and fall you know and he I don't
know and then he actually went through
the whole program and I was like [ __ ]
dude you're 72 and then I found out that
some of these other guys I thought they
were like 50 or 60 years old they're
like 7775 seven yeah I'm just like damn
you guys a strong man the nares black
ball yeah he got he tested and he got
his black belt and then you were like I
ain't sleepin on seven no don't sleep on
70 year olds man you think they're
[ __ ] weak don't [ __ ] you up I got
kicked by a 70 year old man that [ __ ]
wasn't fun
yeah and he was like 76 kicked me in the
[ __ ] stomach I was like damn what the
[ __ ] what did you do to deserve this
he was demonstrating he was Dennis okay
with a bunch of 70 year old did like
what the [ __ ] is Joe doing on a weekend
yeah I bet you this will cheated though
how taxi oh I can't wait till I'm 87 to
beat is hey don't beat us that's crazy
dude the oldest person ever to complete
it you know how a lot of we have a lot
of family members that complain like oh
it's my age I can't do it no more I want
to send them this [ __ ] I'm said you
might be a little [ __ ] yeah I wouldn't
even do that now though at this age
absolutely I won't even beat his time we
know at Joe's position but he started no
70
I know 17w oh you're saying like oh I
was thinking like you have to Train like
right like we would not even already be
able to do that maybe maybe you cuz you
run like five miles in k-town at night
night yeah but I also like run to a bar
afterwards there yeah there's a lot of
training that goes but behind this
because like crappin is no joke man like
the last race I did that was like 13
miles like by the third or fourth mile I
already had like both leg cramps so for
the rest of the race I was barely
[ __ ] jogging and then collapsing
jogging collapsing jog right because the
first three miles was all uphill so then
it just threw out my calves
yeah she did a five-month actually we
okay five miles whatever I did it that's
awesome well I did I did the day before
and she did the day after yeah she's
[ __ ] crazy you did it back to that oh
man after doing that on Saturday on
Sunday with you guys that was like a
freaking walk at the park that [ __ ] was
I know you're like the first one to
finish out of the whole group right no I
stayed back with everybody yeah yeah
that's why didn't see me you thought I'd
passed you up
but I remember towards the end I was
like crawling oh they call my god but my
legs are cramping yes you know that's so
you experienced a 5-mile like this is
like hundreds that's crazy
that's just the marathon's 26 yeah it's
a total of a hundred and forty point six
miles yeah how does his like old ass
heart just pump blood through his body
his [ __ ] dude like I don't understand
that [ __ ] this [ __ ] unreal he's got
that [ __ ] Master Roshi strength man
[Music]